- J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
j'mène une vie d'assassin,
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers.
J'arpente les rues,
sapé comme un moine,
lame dans la manche,
tueur dans l'âme.
Dans l'anonymat,
j'mène une vie semée d'embûches.
J'suis personne, caché sous ma capuche.
Quand j'suis dans la foule,
j'suis sous ma capuche.
Quand j'assassine,
Quand il pleut,
j'suis sous ma capuche.
Quand j'enlève ma capuche,
- Ouais, mais ce que t'as pas dit,
c'est que ta capuche
c'est surtout  pour cacher ta calvitie !
- N'importe quoi !
- Là on dirait juste Gérard Jugnot !
- Pff, trop pas !
- Baby...
- Parmi les Templiers,
je sais m'immiscer.
Je suis déguisé et ma lame est aiguisée.
Un inconnu sombre,
toujours dans la pénombre,
j'me fonds dans la foule,
discret comme une ombre.
- Sauf que là, mec,
t'es dans une foule d'enfants,
et tu mesures 1,85 m !
Tout le monde te voit, baby !
Même l'instituteur...
- J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
j'mène une vie d'assassin,
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers.
J'grimpe sur les toits,
j'arpente les abbayes,
tout en acrobaties...
Yamakasi !
Quel héros à part moi
peut grimper, frapper, tuer,
escalader des cathédrales
avec un style oriental ?
- Prince of Persia !
- Ouais, c'est vrai,
mais moi j'suis quand même fort.
- Et en plus, lui, il peut remonter le temps.
-Bon, d'accord, mais moi, euh...
J'ai un grappin, d'accord ?
Seul contre tous,
j'me bats 1 contre 20,
coup de pied circulaire,
lame dans la jugulaire,
esquive, high-kick, esquive, middle-kick,
parade, uppercut, tomahawk !
- J'te rappelle que t'es branché à l'Animus,
et que dans la vraie vie,
t'es seul chez toi en slip,
sur ton canapé....
On voit ton paquet.
- J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
j'mène une vie d'assassin,
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers.
Malgré cette vie hors-normes,
au fond de moi, j'reste un homme.
Alors parfois, j'monte en haut d'un clocher,
et, mélancolique, je médite.
J'pense à ma vie, longuement,
en contemplant la ville... Longuement.
- Ouais mais prends pas trop ton temps, mec,
parce qu'en bas, y a des pompiers
qui pensent que tu veux te suicider !
Ils ont même déjà tendu un drap !
Ouais...
- T'en fais pas pour moi,
je connais les bayes,
après mon saut de l'ange,
j'atterris dans la paille !
- Si je peux me permettre,
cette paille est un peu mouillée,
et elle va coller à tes vêtements !
Tes vêtements...
- Bon, tu vas la boucler, toi ?
Tu connais pas ma vie, OK  ?
J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
j'mène une vie d'assassin,
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers.
- Oups.
- C'est quoi ça ?
- Je sais pas !
- Le tatouage des Templiers...
- OK, j'suis un traître,
mais moi j'ai un flingue !
T'as quoi de mieux ?
- Une confrérie.
Assassin des Templiers !
Ma lame va te faire regretter
la vie que tu as menée,
les choix que tu as faits
au sein des Templiers,
Je vais faire couler ton sang
tellement abondamment
que même Dexter trouverait ça badant.
- Dexter n'a rien à voir là-dedans,
c'est juste une série américai...
-  J'fais des trucs un peu malsains,
j'mène une vie d'assassin,
à éliminer sans pitié
les Templiers.
Les Templiers...
Assassin des Templiers !
- J'te signale que j'avais un gilet pare-balles,
et qu'un gilet pare-balles
ça arrête aussi les couteaux !
J'suis toujours vivant,
baby...